[Musica]
[Applauso]
bene prima di iniziare vorrei farvi una
domanda quanti di voi sono già stati in
questo posto ad ascoltare diciamo
nell'ultimo anno un concerto di musica
classica
bene benissimo
ecco non dovete vergognarvi
nel senso che solo il 12 per cento degli
abitanti del piemonte dichiara di aver
visto un concerto di musica classica
nell'arco degli ultimi 12 mesi
la prosa non se la cava molto meglio e
il 21 e solo poco meno della metà
dichiara di aver letto un libro
nell'ultimo anno
e quando parlo di libro dico una cosa a
forma di libro
state pensando a tutti alla stessa cosa
sì ecco è normale che pochi di voi si
siano recati in questa sala ha ascoltare
un concerto di musica classica perché
tendenzialmente il pubblico è fermato in
maniera molto diversa
vedete io ho fatto per 25 anni il
musicista professionista e da questo
angolo di visuale mi sono abituato ad
apprezzare intere distese di capelli
azzurri e viola con queste orecchie ho
imparato ad estinguere il suono della
caramella baratti scartata e che poi
batte ritmicamente sul palato delle
dentiere dei signori delle signore in
prima fila ecco sto parlando di quello
che lo zoccolo duro degli abbonati delle
stagioni musicali e teatrali che ha
un'età la cui media è abbondantemente
sopra i 65 anni abbondantemente sopra i
65 anni
e l'estate che separa le due stagioni
spesso un fossato molto
profondo in cui qualcuno di queste
bonati per causa di forza maggiore si
perde e all'inizio della stagione nuova
è sempre più difficile trovare qualcuno
che rimpiazzi il vecchio abbonato
sulla sua sedia il portato più immediato
e che vedete i giovani musicisti sono
giovani e spesso sono molto talentuosi
si ritrovano a suonare per platee che
hanno l'età media dei loro nonni
questo significa perdere l'afflato primo
di chi fa arte che e l'afflato alla
contemporaneità
io vi dico ci sono molti ostacoli per
cui oggi qualcuno possa andare ad
ascoltare un concerto di musica classica
vi faccio un esempio una sonata di
mozart è un brano scritto nel settecento
che prevede secondo la liturgia corrente
che artista e pubblico escono da casa
loro e vadano in un posto costruito
secondo i criteri dell'ottocento
probabilmente edificato o ristrutturato
nel novecento in cui oggi nel xxi secolo
quel brano può essere ascoltato a casa
gratuitamente e non in cambio di un
prezzo di un biglietto su un tablet o
uno smartphone
probabilmente in cinque versioni
spaziali in hd e con delle riprese sulle
mani dell'autore capite quanti ostacoli
non solo economici ci sono fra il
pubblico e l'artista ecco tre anni fa mi
sono posto questo problema come posso
dare a questi giovani esecutori una
platea diversa e ho pensato alla
difficoltà che hanno soprattutto i
trenta quarantenni che hanno dei figli
ad uscire la sera di casa cercando un
nonno qui lasciano il nonno e quello che
l'abbonamento cercando una tata a cui
lasciare i figli per poi andare al
concerto e ritornare a casa pagando il
taxi ma non il loro il tax e la tata
perché i mezzi pubblici è però non ci
sono più ho inventato una cosa che si
chiama adotta un pianista musica da
camera in camera tua dove in orari
diversi
se gli orari del giorno le famiglie con
i loro bambini possono andare delle case
private ad ascoltare dei concerti di
giovani musicisti in un ambiente non
formale accogliente in cui se un bambino
piange non viene visto come uno stigma
ha pianto siamo in sette miliardi sulla
terra qualcosa mi dice che qualcuno fa
finì in questo momento così come in
questo momento a san salvario si stanno
sviluppando dieci concerti di musica
classica nelle case private dove giovani
esecutori e il pubblico ha fatto da
famiglie con bambini si ritrova magari
seduti sui cuscini per terra magari
studio sul letto a vivere in maniera
contemporanea la musica classica e
questo sara nella mia aspirazione il
pubblico degli anni a venire che
ascolterà musica come l'ascolterà non lo
so ma sono sicuro che l'ascolterà adotta
un pianista e la musica da camera in
camera tua se qualcuno di voi ha in casa
propria un pianoforte o un amico che ha
un pianoforte a casa propria
lo tenga presente ne vale la pena grazie
[Applauso]